all right shannon season 15
of the real housewives of orange county
and you
are the closest thing we have to an og
now you're the longest running cast
member
it's it's a little bit insane because
first of all i started in season nine
so that's that's long into a show
so it's it's it's a lot
you are now also una amiga
you are the last amiga standing what
does that feel like
i'm not gonna lie at the very beginning
of filming i was a little concerned
because i i didn't really have close
relationships with any of the cast but
you know what has been nice about it is
that i have been able to develop those
relationships now
that vicky and tamara aren't there
vicky and tamara have had a lot to say
about
the state of things kind of the demise
of their friendship
with you you've stayed pretty quiet what
do you want to say about it
what's your side of the story there i
just want to say that
they have been saying such untruths
about me
in the press and i dispute what they've
said i just kind of felt like as soon as
vicki and i
we are not on the show anymore she just
doesn't have any time for us anymore
and it really just kind of hurts my
feelings because i feel like i've you
know not only lost my job
but i lost my best friend and i'm just
i'm hurt
i'm just hurt because i really i didn't
expect it you know
i guess i wasn't important to her i am
not the person
to sink down to a level to argue
with people that i consider close
friends in the press or on social media
that's not
who i am that's not what i'm made of so
i just i feel like i have a little bit
more decorum
than they do so i'm not i don't want to
engage with them
except to say that the things that
they've been saying especially tamra
it's a laundry list of things that
aren't true
safe to say you're not really in contact
with either of them
at this moment no not at all
no not at all i mean it's it's
interesting when people
say you know you can pick up the phone
what [ __ ] would pick up the phone when
someone's been bashing them for months
on end i mean it almost got
to a point where it was weekly
where and yet another untruth would come
out and
you know it's just i i take the high
road in those situations and i'm going
to continue to do that
do you have any hope for reconciliation
any hope to reunite with them one day or
is that chapter
closed and done because of what's
happened kelly and i have talked about
it a little bit
um i really have no reason to be around
them anymore we live
like 45 minutes away from each other so
it's not like we're in the same
social circles or anything like that
there's i don't know when i would ever
potentially run into them again so i
don't know i suppose i should
never say never because i'm one of those
people that have said i'm done
and then i made my plans and that kelly
dot might be an example of that
uh so never say never but for now i i
don't
i have no desire that makes sense to me
so the door's closed but maybe it's not
locked the deadbolt isn't on
you never know you never know we're
going to see the journey of you
and kelly dodd yes
you know i had um i'm a very loyal
friend
so if you attack my best friend
in my eyes you're attacking me so i had
some revelations
after she kind of explained what she was
doing now i
do what i think her intentions were
towards camera were
were kind or nice no but i took
them personally that she was going after
me as well
and she explained to me that she wasn't
and what she said made sense to me
so you know when i hear that
um i'm gonna give her another chance we
actually are neighbors too
i mean i see her all the time so
like we are when walking distance of
each other so
and i'm i'm glad you know i i don't like
to argue with anyone
as my i do i do have opinions
always and i have no fear of expressing
them
that being said i don't like to be in
arguments with people i just don't
kelly has come under fire a lot in the
last few months
her pandemic related behavior what she's
said about the pandemic
don't we kind of feel like that right
now just go out there and just get
it and like be done with it i mean
that's what kind of like
and when i said
thinning like you know like it's like
darwinism like i don't know like
we listen we have a short life we all do
what's your take on how she's handled
things i don't necessarily agree
with a lot of the things that she said
um it's you know she puts her foot in
her mouth
a lot and that you know it's
not good um you know
when this pandemic first hit i mean i
i was petrified like i couldn't sleep i
i was a mess and um
so and people are still dying from it
it's a serious
illness and you don't know if you're
going to
be seriously affected by or not i mean i
have uh friends
who have lost you know five plus
friends to to uh covet so
um you know there's a certain respect
uh level that i don't think that she had
for what certain people are going
through and i i don't agree with it
let's move on to your other neighbor
bronwyn
she judging by the trailer seems to be
in the center of a lot of the
mess we're gonna see this season if i
can do this
goodbye [ __ ] you gina yeah
she just kind of like i i feel kind of
came in
guns ablazin and i think you see from
the trailer i'm not
pleased with some of the things that
she's done shannon was the one that's
like he is kind of sad
don't you dare accuse me of something
that i did i go don't
what is it i say don't tell me i did
something that i did and i meant to say
didn't you know i i was throwing a party
i didn't do it
so anyways but yeah it's just like
that is my button don't tell me
that i said something when i know i
didn't say it like
i know i remember what i say and do i do
yeah i figured you just misspoke out of
frustration in the moment
but i think you can tell from the
concept talk from the context of my
words like
what stupid person would say don't tell
me i
did something that i did so i mean
that's just when my
sometimes my mind is going in 50 million
directions and then i'm on to the next
and i've
cut the other one off you say bronwyn
came in guns of blazing do you think she
stirs up drama for the sake of stirring
up drama does stuff for the attention
well i think that you'll see this season
um some of us
kind of um
perplexed a little bit about what's
what's going on with her
i mean i don't want to i don't want to
ruin anything but
um yeah all of us kind of have our
antennas race with runway this teaser
was the love shack real
was it really she an author
okay you're raising some questions here
we also have a new girl
elizabeth vargas who i do not know what
to expect from this woman
after seeing her social media after
seeing the premiere
i'm intrigued oh yeah oh yeah elizabeth
vargas has got
fun what is your take on elizabeth
vargas
she's a lot elizabeth vargas is a lot i
think that
you know i i had fun with her i people
of course when when you know who a new
cast member is you know i had people
calling me texting me trying to give me
intel
but i always like to try and meet
someone on my own and you know
not normal for me but i i liked her when
i first met her
and she was fun um but you know we kind
of
have a little something too i don't know
what's wrong with shannon she just
turned like that does she do that yeah
she's a very complex person and i'll
i'll just leave it at that
a lot of layers
that feels right to me after seeing the
premiere but it is she is kind of the
first new girl that
you're starting off on at least a good
foot with most of the girls it's shaky
ground
i started out well with bronwyn let's
not forget
okay i'll take it i don't know who the
new girl was before her
um lydia
[Laughter]
your mother said i had a bright light
maybe you should talk to her a little
bit
okay well she also said you're a lost
soul i'm done and done
all right if you had to boil down what
we're gonna see in season 15 to one word
what is your word for season 15 oh
i would say unique because it's
something that's not
normal i mean we're what we've been
going through
as as the whole world has been going
through something that's never really
happened in history so
so it's just you can't even script some
of this stuff
and so i just think it's going to be a
very unique experience for the
audience and you know for them to maybe
compare what they were going through as
we were
all locked up at home too um i
i think it's going to be interesting i
think it is going to be entertaining
um because everyone's going to be able
to relate to the things that all of us
went through
well i'm excited to see the rest of it
and i think people need to i've seen
some chatter about like i don't want to
re-watch the pandemic but it's like
we're still
in it i want to see how you guys handled
it i want to see what you were able to
turn like
turn lemons into lemonade to make us a
show you know take the nine lemons out
of the bowl
well i have to tell you rice i've been
told that
it's it's just gonna be like an episode
or a little bit more than one episode
it's not gonna be like you know
five weeks of coving
[Music]
stuff
[Music]
you